there are it seems no deaths of star
wars obscurity which john favreau will
not plumb
no peek of nerd minutia that he will not
summit from the practical purpose of an
ice cream maker in space
to the return of mcclunkey the
mandalorian has now spent two full
seasons
sinking its teeth into some of the most
pedantic references available
met at every term with fan appreciation
in the closing moments of the show's
second season finale
longtime fans got a big surprise in the
form of a return visit to the star wars
galaxy's most evocatively smelly looking
den of scum and villainy
jabba's palace last seen in live action
during the events of return of the jedi
for an all too brief moment viewers got
to catch up with old friends like
background weak way enslaved twilight
number 14
and the best of all a bib fortuna jabba
sniveling toady from episode 6
and the show runners didn't stop there
true to form they included an even more
obscure reference in their post-credits
sting
for the book of boba fett and like some
of their other callbacks you didn't even
need to be an obsessive fan to spot it
you just needed to have 2.99 back in
1983.
it all goes back to the original trilogy
merchandising and the fact that action
figures which absolutely are not dolls
need to accessorize star wars action
figures were especially well regarded in
the field of adding weird extra bits of
plastic
to sweeten the deal for kids with each
addition nearly tripling the odds of
losing part of your favorite toy
to a vacuum cleaner an especially
popular accoutrement for any given
action figure
was a vaguely stick shaped thing admiral
akbar had a stick thing for some reason
so did general maiden and bib fortuna
well bib fortuna had the most
stick-shaped thing of all
yes kenna's original return of the jedi
tie-in bib fortuna action figure
carried with him a long twisty staff a
weird detail
considering that the character never had
one in the movie but hey
gross pale fleshy headed criminal guy is
a tough sell
and kids love walking sticks right maybe
this was the same stuff that favreau and
company gave to bib in his brief
appearance
at the end of the mandalorian second
season finale with any luck
this won't be the last action figure
callback in the series and next season
will feature the return of luke
skywalker
now with collector coin and saber slam
action attack batteries sold separately
of course
however by this point you're probably
wondering who this bib fortunate guy is
in the first place
sure he was in jabba's palace and you
know he's a guy with a bumpy tentacle
head but every star wars character has a
super elaborate backstory don't they
and maybe somewhere in that backstory
there might be an explanation for his
stuff
thankfully the mighty star wars loving
aficionados at wikipedia have foreseen
this great question
and are here to answer any and or
questions about who bib fortuna is on a
deeper level
unfortunately it seems that the history
of his staff in canon that is remains
unanswered but thankfully some details
about bim fortuna himself
have been established he is a tweed leg
from the planet ryloth
who at some point rose to become the
second in command to jabba the hutt
tatooine's infamous crime lord as it
happens a rancor scene in return of the
jedi
you know the one they tried to kill off
luke with was previously a birthday
present that bib fortuna gave to his
master
which is frankly about as weird as
birthday presents get
earning this prestigious position was
for the record a tough battle
his main competitor for the role a guy
named bid low kwerv ended up being
sacrificed to the aforementioned rancor
and has thus only been seen on film as a
usefully placed skull in return of the
jedi
dubious hiring practices aside bib
fortuna worked alongside his master
for decades going back all the way to at
least the phantom menace
following jabba's death the mandalorian
shows that he took great pleasure in
gaining control of his former bosses
palace slaves and fortunes
up until his rather unfortunate for him
encounter with boba fett
behind the scenes bib fortuna has been
played by a few actors
scottish actor michael carter was the
original and the characters subsequent
appearances in both the phantom menace
and the mandalorian have seen matthew
wood take the role
is he coming back probably not as you
saw in the mandalorian it seems that bib
fortuna has met his maker
and ascended into whatever mysterious
afterlife the star wars universe
possesses
but hey at least he got to finally hold
that cool action figure style staff
before kicking
the bucket right check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite tv
shows and movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]